uh him uh playing and singing with the
lieutenant dan
band there let me let me just ask you
this in difficult times where
uh our great national holiday has
apparently become
uh controversial you can't sing
god bless the usa and fake it
can you you've got it you got to mean it
when you do that song
well we do uh we do do that song mark hi
it's good to be with you
um we've done that song uh in my band
for uh oh about 18 years now
uh at the end of our show it always
closes our show lee greenwood
wrote a great patriotic ant
uh to the united states and uh and it
always plays well with our audience uh
they
they know the song they sing along with
it and you know most of our audience is
uh military veterans first responders
we played hundreds of concerts for them
and their families and that that is
always
a a big treat right at the end of our
show
uh i can't think of any other character
from a movie
that became a band there's there's no uh
scarlet o'hara band there's no mary
poppins band
but there is a lieutenant dan band
and we somehow i take it presumably by
accident
a character you played in a movie
connected
with millions of real veterans
as somehow getting to the heart of what
it is
uh to serve and to suffer in
a war that ends ambiguously or ends in
defeat
and yet there is still nobility and
glory
in having served your country
well mark i um
a couple years ago i wrote a book called
grateful american
a journey from self-disservice and it
counteracts
how i got into all this with our
military and it starts with the family
members in my in my family world war one
world war ii
korea era vietnam a lot of veterans in
my family
i ended up playing the vietnam veteran
in forrest gump and
and at that time i had
done very little i just hadn't hadn't
worked in the movie or television
business uh for very long at all when i
started going out and visiting troops
around the world and going to the
hospitals
uh most of them didn't know who i was
but they knew lieutenant dan they
knew my face from the moon so when i
started taking the band with me
on these tours i just said let's call it
gary sinise
lieutenant dan bandel at least know uh
that uh the guy who played the character
is coming to see him and
since then as i said we've played
hundreds of concerts
the band is a program of my foundation
the gary sinise foundation
so much like when you support the uso
and they send entertainment if you
support the gary sinise foundation one
of the things that we do
we we send the band out and you can help
us do that by going to
garysnessfoundation.org
let me let me just ask you finally uh
gary what
uh as i said these are weird times when
a national holiday becomes controversial
you've played a lot on july the fourth
you played a lot on memorial day what
does
independence day mean to you personally
well it's hardly controversial uh to me
i mean it it's about freedom and
uh i having gone to places around the
world
the war zones of afghanistan iraq
places like that where they don't really
understand what freedom is
i've stood on the border between north
and south korea several times
they're free in the south and slaved
enslaved in the north
you value your freedom that much more
and you value the people that provide it
for you
and that's the men and women of the
united states military that's why i
started my foundation
i want to support them in every way i
can because
freedom is precious and uh it has to be
fought for it has to be protected
independence from a tyranny has to be
fought for and protected and i thank god
for the men and women who
are willing to do that and i just want
to help them out
well god bless you gary and god bless
the usa you've done great work for the
next 10 years and i'm sure there are
moments when you'd much rather
be on a sound stage or
in a theater but you do this work you
are a great actor and a great patriot
and that combination doesn't always go
together as often as it should thank you
so much this independence day weekend
gary
sinise okay sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else